all right i think the double push sort
of mutes it all right we are here for a
special committee on redistricting work
session today is october 20th we are
here on official state business so i
would like to start the meeting with the
pledge of allegiance and if you would
rise and join me
i pledge allegiance to the book of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
welcome committee members um you have an
agenda in front of you i do not
um
anticipate any votes on things of
substance one of the main goals is to
reach some sort of a consensus on moving
forward
as you are aware as of today we have
completed a public input session in each
county i want to thank representative
smith
for
sharing a few of those meetings that i
did not attend and i want to thank
committee members for attending those
meetings i think everybody attended at
least one and there are some members
here who
attended everyone
and they are to be
commended in light of that
because there were some long drives
there um i have a few extras here they
were passed out originally
but i understand people may not have
them they are to be submitted to the
speaker's office for reimbursement
representative weber
thank you madam chair that was the first
thing that you would ask me to remind
you of but you got to it before i did i
also wanted to ask that um our records
include the letter that i submitted
there's a copy to each of you
on your desks it is from
uh and i'm submitting it as a member of
the committee and as ranking member of
health human services and elderly
affairs it's a letter to the speaker
from 25. i am aware of your organization
thank you representative and i would
just like it to be part of our records
as well as uh in the speakers i don't
know why it would be part of our records
i think that opens up every committee
member to submit anything that is
submitted to the speaker of the house
i appreciate your concern with the
issues raised but it is not addressed to
the committee it does not reference the
committee it is a letter to the speaker
and it is signed by a number of
individuals
i suspect many of whom are not even from
new
from they look like most of them are
from new hampshire
and i have no personal knowledge as to
why this would be part of the record so
i am going to decline the request to
make it part of the public record of
this committee you have referenced it
and it will of course be has been
submitted to the speaker thank you for
bringing it to our attention
i i would then just ask that
we all think very clearly about
the requests made therein because they
are the same as requests made by many
many many of our citizens so i thought
adding the extra voices in
would be useful to the committee thank
in regards to
public requests i just wanted to see if
any members had anything
specific in regards to the public input
sessions other than the issues of access
quite frankly because those have been
raised repeatedly and i don't think they
need to be raised
again but as to the issues before us on
redistricting
did any members have anything in
particular they wanted to raise for the
committee this morning i'm sure some a
lot of it will come up as we discuss
representative lane
thank you for those sessions i was not
able to attend personally i watched them
on streaming and i can tell you i don't
know if anybody else has watched them
it's really hard to hear some of the
speakers and what they're saying so as
we have additional hearings
we need to really remind them to speak
up because if people are watching
it's really hard to hear and it's hard
to hear the members too yeah the and we
we were dealing with different
microphones in every setting so
hopefully going forward we're going to
have microphones we're all more familiar
with so we'll be able to deal with that
better
um one of the things i did want to talk
about because i think it was mentioned
at every public setting was the website
i want to make sure committee members
are going on the website to check input
i've gone through it to just review it i
did not make copies of the website
submissions for everybody but i just
wanted to go through it so committee
members remain aware of what's going on
and the public does also
in regards to submission of testimony to
the committee that can be written or
files map files it does say very clearly
on the website that the files need to be
in a pdf format
there have been some problems uploading
hopefully
any problems have been resolved and
clarification that it needs to be pdf
has resolved them there is a location
for general testimony
as of yesterday at 4 30 and that's
that's when i have the data from there
had been 40 submissions to the general
testimony link of course people have
comments that relate to all
of the mapping endeavors we're taking on
and you heard that in the sessions
there is also a link for hb 51 this
deals with state senate districts
our public input sessions were joint
sessions with the senate as of 4 30
yesterday afternoon there had been a
total of three submissions now this is
the house website so i am not
particularly surprised by that i would
expect that people that had specific
comments might be commenting to the
senate
as we've discussed i expect those maps
to be done in the first instance by the
senate who in their typical fashion has
not yet had their organization meeting
we are way ahead
um
the next
bill we have is hb 52 with congressional
districts
as of 4 30 yesterday afternoon there had
been a total of
eight
comments sometimes it's hard for me to
on this particular website you would
have the opportunity
website link you will have the
opportunity to see submitted maps there
is one submitted map on the senate site
there are four submitted maps on the hb
52 link
those do include the mapathon a handout
that members received at an earlier
meeting
hb 53 deals with executive council
districts there have been three comments
on that site and again
uh there is one submission that contains
maps and that would be the mapathon
submission that this committee has seen
and then h.b 54 for county commissioners
had two comments as of yesterday and
actually did have a map submission for
one of our counties
and as i'm doing this it looks like i
didn't print out the house comments
there are house comments online i
don't have the exact number
and i think there might be one or two
maps on that link so i just raised that
to remind
members of the public that you could
submit
testimony in pdf format at that link and
to
request committee members to stay
updated on what we're receiving on those
direct emails from constituents also
does anybody have any questions about
the website and access representative
weber
i beg your pardon i guess i just wanted
to make
sure that i had it clear
um what happens with the emails that we
get because
in the normal time our emails don't
become part of the committee's records
unless they are submitted as a paper
copy or in this case uploaded onto the
website so i'm just i'm just wondering
what's happening with all the emails i
suspect what happens with every other
house committee at this time hopefully
members are reading them and filing them
as they deem appropriate
we are getting emails
on a fairly consistent basis to the
committee
i will say that in my review of the
emails as compared to the submitted
testimony the submitted testimony on the
website appears to be more on point to
actual mapping as compared to the emails
we've been receiving
anybody else on this issue
representative fedora it's piedra madame
i apologize i'll write it out
phonetically no problem i just wanted to
clarify on the website i was not i don't
see a specific section for comments on
house maps just general testimony senate
county
congressional is that how it should be
or should there be a separate section no
i think there's there should be one for
house if the are you looking at it right
now
okay email to it
maybe that's why i didn't print it out
yesterday yesterday seems a long time
ago to me right now just so you know
thank you for clarifying that you're
welcome
christina if you can send an email to it
that would be terrific and if you get a
response while we're still in session
can you let me know what it is
an issue was raised yesterday morning
and communicated with it that there were
problems uploading to the site and maybe
they've had to take it down for
maintenance
but hopefully we'll get an answer to
that and thank you
for raising that
you have in front of you a copy of the
letters
of a sample letter that was sent to the
cities this was sent to berlin
i asked lindsay to
just print out a sample
of the letter that was sent to every
city this is actually sort of perfect
because berlin does not actually have
wards and i have already received a call
from them saying we don't have wards
don't give us wards
so i have assured them we will not be
doing that and uh representative
bergeron and representative lane
if we want copies of the letters to each
city will get them after the meeting
has anybody heard from any cities in
regards to this other than my call from
berlin
representative bergeron no i haven't
heard anything yet from any of the
cities
okay great thank you um and that leads
to the you should have all now everybody
in this room
oh excuse me representative o'hara
i did talk to the mayor of laconia and
laconia has put their lines drawn up
they just haven't voted yet oh they
already have them done yeah so again
from scott myers the city manager all
right if you can get the the population
numbers for those that will be terrific
i'm assuming they're pretty close to
equal so it shouldn't affect our mapping
at this point really yeah that was their
goal okay
great representative lane
i was told informally by the mayor of
concord that we would have them i think
he said by the end of october so i'm
going to follow up with him but he said
he would definitely have them to us in
time by the 18th
wow great
all right
the thumb drives you should have
received
have this city wards with the population
allocation that's closer to what we
expect as compared to what it is
currently
so hopefully that will assist you in
your map drawing it also includes a
program for the county commissioner
districts which you could do
with the other programs
but this will make it easier
so if you don't have a thumb drive let
me know and i think we need to figure
out how to get it to representative cody
there should be one more but everybody
in here should have those thumb drives
the next
representative weber
i'd volunteer to deliver that if you'd
um
i think you volunteered for the last one
or somebody delivered the last one i
think
okay
all right the next thing i wanted to
talk about with the full committee was
scheduling
we are through the public input sessions
so we need to do some scheduling
there have been some tentative
discussions about scheduling things can
change of course
but i wanted to run through it with the
committee with my logic and then move
forward from today we need to report out
by november 18th
that means
we need to have votes on all of our
i believe we should allocate the
possibility of meeting for at least one
day if not two that week to get through
those
discussions
so plan on meeting
and if we get done on the 16th we won't
a request made pretty much at every
hearing for public to be able to have
input on maps after they're selected
so we will have as we in concord as we
public input sessions on these bills the
tentatively
that will be
two days it may be a morning and an
afternoon
the actual schedule has not been
determined
and to be quite honest with you right
now i can't remember whether i requested
reps haul for the 8th and the 9th or the
9th and the 10th
and so i will update you
committee members by email but that
meeting in reps hall
for public input
on maps will be the week of the 8th
november 11th is veterans day thursday
which means that we need to as a
committee vote on maps to go
in front of the public for comment the
following week
so
my preference would be to have a meeting
on the third to be able to go into the
fourth but i want some committee
feedback on that because i am more than
happy to go the fourth leaving the fifth
open
because we can continue
the meeting
i think the clerk would probably like to
um
but these are really work session votes
not vote executive session
votes the executive sessions will be the
week of the 15th
so really for the calendar we're talking
notices so i guess
i'm going to look for a committee
consensus on whether to start this
process of actually going through the
maps and voting on wednesday or thursday
i would just note that i have a con for
a conflict on the third but if if that's
the
what's most convenient for the committee
of course we'll get a substitute
okay
all right i'm going to look to
representative bergeron
um
who i have loaded up with two meetings
today with one on election law so i'm
trying to defer to him
in regards to his city duties because
november 2nd are city elections
me personally it doesn't matter because
i won't be working at the polls and i
won't be assisting the clerk uh current
clerk anymore with elections okay so
it really doesn't matter to me third or
okay all right does it representative
smith has to leave for a few minutes so
anybody else on a preference for what
day to start that would be all my
baggage behind me that he just stripped
over
all right how many want to start on
wednesday
show a hands
one two three four five six how many
want to start on thursday
one two three
four
five
i think i would prefer to start on
wednesday
just because
i want to make sure we get through it
so let's
start on wednesday do you have a
conflict all day representative weber
okay
my meetings in berlin and
so the likelihood of my getting back in
time for anything
without getting arrested is very
unlikely
okay
and i i may have a conflict on thursday
morning as well but that depends on the
berlin court schedule so i i just really
think given the schedule and what we're
doing we're stuck with that week
it makes entirely good sense and i just
okay
it occurred to the chair that she should
my husband will have to deal with the
[Laughter]
all right so
if we're having committee meetings on
the third and the fourth
we are here on the 20th
um it becomes an issue at that at this
point i think as to how we want to
and i say this because
now
i haven't particularly put a call out
for maps but
i haven't seen many
and we need to have maps at meetings to
vote on so
representative mcguire has kindly done
some work on maps with the programs that
we've had now for quite a while and you
have that handout
so i would i am going to ask
representative mcguire to go through
so that as a committee we can make some
decisions on when things have to be
submitted and if this format
works
we are going to deal with paper
because
with the room that spread like this to
do things on a screen is simply
impractical
and i want to have control over what
everybody is looking at to be sure it is
the same
yes so
thank you madam chair
thank you
all right i worked on three counties
belknap
grafton and merrimack
there are some printing issues due to
so
these these packages are not quite as
complete as i might like
but we'll go through them
the top is a region a representatives
district for merrimack county
and the towns are on the
page three
bill nap yes excuse me they're an
alphabetical or they're not in
alphabetical order oh yeah okay
merrimack is two sheets in
yeah there's a so we'll start with
bellnap because it's smaller
okay the first map which is on the cover
shows
districts
and there's a listing of them
so that each ward of laconia gets its
own representative
and then there's a floaterial over the
um
oh okay then there's barnstead belmont
and gilmanton with five reps
which is bigger than i might like but
the size of the town pretty much
prevented me from doing anything else
alton and guilford for four reps
meredith sanborn
and tilton for four
and then center harbor and new hampton
for one
and
this the
interesting part about this is that the
the whole county
that has very inconvenient sizes for
every town
and it was really impossible to give
and what is the resulting deviation
range when you use
5.29
okay
so as the committee is aware
we're shooting for plus or minus five so
we're running well this is this is
actually skewed lower it's minus six to
two minus point seven eight
because of the size of the county so
this could i'm sure this could be
improved but it it's a first pass that
seems to meet the requirements
all right so what you have is a printout
of the map and then the printout of the
towns with reps with deviations
so and was this all available from the
program that we're working from yes
ma'am all right and just a printout from
from it okay now there were some issues
in regards to printing this out so how
did those end up getting resolved
um
i managed to
at if i were at home i could have just
printed from the program
because i wasn't at home i had to
manipulate it into a pdf
and then email that to our staff
all right so i'm i'm raising that issue
so committee members when you're working
on maps you need to be aware of what
you're on
for purposes of transmission and it was
it was a
convoluted process to get the map in pdf
and then
yes thank you representative
disagreeing with me
the uh
the list of towns with deviations is a
cut and paste that's much easier to get
okay
and then all right anybody have any
questions on belnap
no ma'am but there are no floaters
except the one in laconia the second one
is the county commissioners oh oh okay
it's just there aren't any labels yes
well like i said there's some some
the county the second the back of the
first page is the commissioners yes
representative smith
i
um
the lists here the left hand column says
total seats 19 the right
18.
there are 19 seats in
in
in bellnap
for
since i was using the reps map
pro this was before the county program
got before the county program i just
made it for six so the numbers would be
appropriate the these this isn't the
exact deviation
but the the spread should be about right
it will have to be just because as i
said you could do the counties but you
ended up doing the deviation spread
based on reps so that's why your number
of reps is slightly off if you're using
the new program that we have that can
get fixed does not have it have an even
19 is not divisible by 3 evenly so i had
to do it with an approximation
but if you look at the population of the
three districts
2589 and 21
48 which should give you an idea of how
close they are
representative lane
thank you and thank you for doing this
this is awesome um
the bottom of the
the one for the wraps the page yeah
there's that little triangle there
that's barnstead okay the rest of
barnstead is falling off has fallen off
the page i figured that
okay thank you in fact it fell off on
both maps yeah but it's still barnstead
okay
we haven't forgotten barnstein
representative weber
thank you with respect to the
commissioner's district and the total
seat sea schools 18 i understand the
concept of nine not being 19 not being
divisible are you
assuming that the commissioner district
should track the um
should track the other districts or
no the commissioner district should be
as equal as possible it's just that's
the way the way you had to do it to get
it to print out correct okay i got it
yes no the
well i could who calculate the
deviations by hand but it's
it would be a pain so
the hold on representative mcguire
representative barry
uh yes uh thank you representative
mcguire for doing all these so you you
noted in your
initial testimony
or your statement i should say that it's
it's sometimes very difficult to
give each town its own rep in belknap
county specifically because of how off
they are from the standard deviation um
if you in you looked at any other
counties have you kind of seen that
around or is that just that could be a
built up county problem or is that going
to be a problem it's a problem
everywhere
because if if nothing else the easiest
way to give every town their rep is to
have enormous flow tarials
which we heard even more we heard even
more testimony against
than for every town to get their rep
even the people that
are in small towns that don't so they
weren't demanding their own rep were
okay so and yes it is a problem
but
thank you madam chair to answer rep
barry's uh
problem we did hear at almost every one
of our public input sessions individuals
saying if we have a minimum of the 3444
we deserve our own rep
um
i think it's very important for people
to understand that that's
in some cases an impossibility and i've
got a great great example for everybody
to look at
if you look down in the southeast corner
we don't have it right here but well
then you don't have it for us to look at
we are not talking about maps at any
point if people are not looking at them
because it just gets too
confusing
and they're not you know we're not
submitting anything for people to
um consider and vote but i i think that
that sort of
hearing that issue i actually got a big
kick out of that issue because we were
sitting there with senators and people
were complaining about the size of
districts and representation and i'm
sort of looking over at the senators
going how's that working out for you um
i'm just wondering for comparison
purposes and i would do this if i could
if i could actually do the maps but i
can't because i don't have technology
that actually there's technology
downstairs in what used to be the
smoking room for all representatives to
use okay well i will try and do that my
understanding was that they didn't want
um
stuff uploaded on those because of
i could be wrong about that that that's
a memory from a long time ago so this
came from i.t so if there's an issue we
need to talk to i.t
i i will check those out and thank you
okay i just i'm wondering if it's
possible to
try and compare because i as as
representative mcguire did i heard that
the comment about
enormous flow tarials don't make a lot
of sense
but
what i also heard from people was
if if we could get
the underlying representation as small
as possible then maybe the enormous flow
materials don't matter it's easier to
actually get the deviations right if you
do it the way representative mcguire did
it because you have a little more to
play with in each in each case well
we've got 15 members so we can have 15
maps
there we go
in this case try and figure that out
i'm going to make work for other people
yeah well let's make work for some
people but we've got some people
apparently doing all the work and other
people maybe not so
part of that discussion is going to be
where are these maps going to come from
and when are we going to get them
continue representative
thank you madam chair in belknap county
i tried believe me
okay
this don't work exactly and i've got a
few more all right so for county
commissioners
normally in the case of a county
commissioner
you
you try not to split up the cities
but it was impossible to come up with
anything close to
plus or minus five percent without
breaking up laconia because of the way
and again this is a a draft and i would
love to have somebody do it better
but
representative herrera i hear your name
being called in regards to belknap
county issue for division of the city
for county commissioners
okay no it's it's it's the county it's
three districts exactly
and the alton barnstead belmont
gilmanton district
is
too big
but there's no other way to do it
because they aren't adjacent to anything
smaller
you know you've
you've got to cover alton and barnstead
somehow
and swapping guilford and belmont would
just make it worse not better
so
there are three districts so what you're
saying is belknap county has issues
belknap county has issues yes i wouldn't
go
so far say they're insurmountable but it
it was difficult okay the second
district is the is the northeast
guilford center harbor meredith new
hampton
and one ward of laconia
and the other one is the rest of laconia
plus sanbornton and tilton
and they're
they're within deviation but
uh it's not i'm not proud of it i'd love
to have somebody come up with something
better
okay
which has
conveniently 45 reps so the
county commissioners was easy
all right
for
let's see the list of towns is on page
five and i'm afraid that due to
due to printing issues it doesn't
all right but part of this exercise is
to give everybody an idea of what we can
do and what we can take a look at this
one is
if we didn't quite get all of them
but
um
the first one is london newbury sutton
and wilmot for three reps
if
you could give new london its own rep
but then you would give the other
district would have a deviation of
greater than five percent
uh
i think was 5.2
and so i chose to include new london in
with the smaller towns that are adjacent
there are a lot of a lot of small towns
in the north in the north and west
the second district is franklin all
three dis all three wards
then northfield has a rep
and there's a floatarial over franklin
and northfield which is fairly similar
danbury hill andover salisbury and
webster
with two reps
i would have liked to put andover and
hill together to make one rap district
but that leaves danbury floating out
causing trouble for everybody else
so combine them
boscoin gets its own rep
loudon is with canterbury as currently
and then there's a fairly large
floaterial over
from danbury to loudon
i'm sure there are there are other ways
to do it but that that works nicely
um
henniker
is with bradford and warner which are
each too small to have their own rep
and it comes out to be
a three rep district
hopkinton is with
concord ward 5 as currently for another
dunbarton and hooksett comes out with
the other war bow is with
um i think it's ward 7
and then they and um
in a three rep district
then the other wards get each get their
pamper could try gesture together for
epsom and pittsfield together because
pitchfield has actually gotten smaller
unfortunately so we have to
we have to get give the same base
district to the two towns
almost town gets its own and then
there's a floatarial over the three
towns
again this works the numbers work
i've i've made the flow tarials as small
as i could but
i'm sure there's room for improvement
thank you any questions on the rep map
as
drafted
um representative lane um thank you um
i have looked at this i haven't done a
map the way that you've done it is there
no way to keep concord together as or
just keep it as it is now and have ward
5 share
with hopkinton
it that leaves beau out in the middle
with with a major
deviation um okay i couldn't find one if
you can to be interesting okay yeah we
know we've been working on it so yeah
well
no i was just curious because it's it is
a
problem okay well thank you
fortunately the towns adjacent to
concord
are
are well integrated into it
there's no question that you know
if you drive on 3a you can see how
concord goes into bell with the
okay commissioners from the commissioner
district
uh that that one we did i did keep
concord together
and conquered plus bow is a third of the
county
almost exactly you could see the numbers
it's
for 15 reps so that works
and then you divide the other two up the
rest of the county
uh
to get your fifty to get the other two
two districts
uh these the at the
on this plan
the two other districts other than
concord are within uh
seven
people
so i think that's about as good as we
there are other plans that would work
it keeps franklin which is the only
other city
in one district
and
although it wasn't one of my goals it
also means that the three current
commissioners are each in one district
it just happens
um
but
okay so that's
very nice
all right and then there's uh grafton
but
you can you can look there's the map of
the
districts and the map of the
commissioners and then the list actually
they got the list of towns correct for
the
house districts
so you can see that they're all
within
less than eight percent
four point eight to minus three
so that's a very close deviation for the
house districts
um they're all as small as i could make
them and no floatarials except one in
lebanon
littleton and monroe for two two seats
bethlehem and fraconia for one
a stack of small towns easton land off
lisbon lyman and sugar hill for one
bath benton haverhill and piermont for
two
ellsworth lincoln livermore thornton
warren waterville and woodstock for two
one for campton by itself
two for plymouth by themselves
and three in
kanan dorchester enfield grafton groton
and orange
they specifically asked to be kept
together
but for three reps which is what they're
worth
the numbers just don't work
orford romney and wentworth for one
uh alexandria ashland bridgewater
hand over and lime together for four it
can't be fewer because the
the size of lime
and then
each wart of lebanon gets a wrap and a
floaterial over the three over the
entire city
which comes out nicely
and
and again on the on the map it got cut
off a little bit at the bottom but
i
couldn't get onto the airport wi-fi
properly so it took a while
um
but
and then you took a look at the
commissioners commissioners yes um the
one one district
lebanon hanover and enfield
which is
30 000 people
second district
which is
uh you can see the edge of it on the map
it's
it
kanan is is the light triangle just next
to hanover and then it goes up through
dorchester wentworth warren ellsworth
over to campton and then down so it's
that section
of the county
and then the other district is lime
orford pyramid haverhill
and over to waterville valley
and those two districts are again
very similar in population
not quite as close as merrimack but
close
and
the deviation on the county is
approximately
so
okay before i take questions
um
representative
piedra
i see you've got your computer open are
you checking the website is it there yet
can you take it can you take a check and
let me know representative
could i suggest that we find a way to
make sure
that
the printing part doesn't fall on
individual members of this committee we
ought to have a very clear way
to do this to do it in color in 2022 we
ought to be able to do this in politics
well and if you note on the agenda we
have an issue in regards to getting maps
to staff before meetings so that they
can be copied and labeled yes i i sent
it to to the staff but they
but our assistant didn't have access to
the program
right so we'll we'll have to make sure
that she gets it
because you can print it from the
program
in it quite
quite much more easily than you can from
from me trying to manipulate it into
something that i can email so we may
need to do i may need to deal with staff
in regards to who do we need to get on
these when they come in because i'm not
sure that one assistant dealing with
printing these is going to be sufficient
still not there
okay
yeah i have to apologize but this is the
best
representative mcguire no apologies
necessary um and it is the map so
um representative mcguire has gone
through using the program that we have
um she's provided this information what
does committee member send says to is
this the information we're looking for
i am getting a consensus that this is
this is what we need to get as compared
to well i mean the option is just a map
um the option is no map just numbers i
mean people might
want to submit other things but i'm
looking for a minimum to staff for us to
have at some point before a meeting so
that we have in front of us what we're
going to address
representative lane
i guess i i would
like them before the meetings in this
form so we can't compare them
my other suggestion which i'm sure
people aren't
it's going to be mixed but
we could do this
and have it up and move it on the
computer and have somebody show us why
it doesn't work i mean it is possible to
do that but i don't know
i mean technology wise i don't know if
that's too much to set up or if
everybody doesn't have a computer you
know maybe that's a problem but i know
that you can move them around and we can
do it on zoom and share the screen and
move it around and show how so she could
show us what she did and
why having say one town as a separate
one didn't work i i just
i think if members i am not
going to go down that route because
um
i'm not sure everybody has the same
access to computers
we're going to have substitutes on
committees i know i'm not going to be
able to have a computer in front of me
and follow it and and share the meeting
and go through it
um and
there are issues just as representative
smith indicated it was helpful to label
it i'm i'm concerned when we're talking
about computer screens and being able to
follow what goes on i am going to allow
members to have computers in front of
them
for this i am not raising issues with
that but i know not everybody has a
computer in front of them so
i i get that approach and i understand
it but hopefully by getting it to
committee members before the meeting and
we need to talk about when
if there are particular deviation issues
that you want to address you'll have an
opportunity to do so
i will also note that going through
these
i think took about a half an hour does
that
sound about i wrote down i thought about
writing down what time we started
actually i wrote down
9 30.
so it took an hour and a half
i'm looking at somebody in the does
anybody have any idea what time we
started talking about representative
mcguire
we didn't start the meeting until 10 so
it was 10 30. i'm sure we started this
meeting around
20 after 20 maybe maybe 30 after it all
right i'm raising that so it was at
least a half an hour to go through this
without any discussion on alternative
maps so i'm raising that so people have
an idea of how much time this is going
to take to go through these
so other comments on the on the
presentation
representative smith i'm sorry you had
um
my inclination would be
24 hours and here's why we're probably
starting our meetings on tuesday or
wednesday
if this is anything like me getting a
report done for the court
or papers done for school it will be
done the weekend before
which means staff will get it on monday
and
um
so 48 hours is just not going to make it
for for a wednesday meeting so
okay
no no i i i agree that unless we recess
so people can go do something by
consensus and come back to look at
something in the course of deliberations
i can see that happening but
um as far as maps to be presented i
think
i understand wanting to have them but
i'm trying to consider the workflow and
if they're available before 24 hours
there's no reason why they can't be
distributed but
i think the cutoff needs to be 24 hours
representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair uh since we're
talking about making maps available in
advance of meetings i'm curious if there
is
an amount of time that you think is
acceptable
or that is a goal for making maps
available ahead of the public hearing
well that's not going to be able to
occur until we have a consensus on what
is going to happen and that won't occur
till the week before the public input
sessions in repsol so
it will be
then
we're not i'm
to put maps up people are free to post
what maps they want as far as testimony
but as far as committee
product that will be the week before the
reps hall meeting
that's why we're scheduling probably two
representative lane um
sorry
to go back to scheduling are we meeting
next week
i had originally
thought we would meet next week but as i
ran through this schedule again and
realized that
mapping a substantial mapping my
suspicion still needs to occur
i
am reassessing my
thought that a meeting next week would
be of value given that we seem we've
gone through a sample
and where we want maps to be submitted i
am thinking that it makes more sense to
let people spend their time next week
working on maps and make sure that
they're all into staff
so that
we can get them
um before our meeting on wednesday the
third
okay unless somebody has a specific i
mean tentatively i had mentally thought
of about that we would have a meeting
next week but
i want to make sure if we're coming in
it's for
a valid purpose i stick to drag
everybody in i just wanted to get it on
my schedules as soon as well i mean let
me ask because originally i had thought
we were going to need it but i'm
thinking that given the amount of maps
and preparation that needs to occur that
we're better off scheduling a couple of
days together
as compared to
i'm worried that if we do it next week
and we set maps to be done that then the
next week somebody will have another map
because they didn't get to it and i'd
rather have everybody be able to get to
everything they want to so we can have
it all together
that's fine with me
the other alternative because i had
thought perhaps to work on it today
is to just come in to do county
commissioner maps next week but
i'm not sure that makes a lot of sense
to come in to just do a county
commissioner map maps for every county
i'll see what i can get done
yeah representative lane um thank you so
on the third and fourth is it safe to
say we'll probably start 9 30 or 10 and
basically go the whole day
should we just block off the whole day
or what i would have to say i think
that's probably reasonable okay
let's start at 10
because we know there's going to be
before we sit down
so let's plan on 10 o'clock on the third
all right
um
there is a bill i'm going to move on to
the next thing that i had on my agenda
there is a bill hb 55 in regards to the
state party
representative barry do you have any
expectation of something that might be
happening with hb 55 uh yes madam
chairman um so i've been looking into um
the
delegates to the state party convention
so a a a really brief history for those
watching at home
[Music]
we haven't codified in rsa
how political parties are supposed to
organize um
their
basically their party structure um
parties have the option to
opt out of this process
the democratic party has opted out of
this process the republican party is
still
in this process
so for the way it works is
there are delegates to the state party
convention
each town is guaranteed their own
delegate
those state party delegates
combine with the party nominees for all
the offices so everyone in this room is
a would be a delegate to a state party
convention
coupled with people who are elected
purely for delegates so hb 55 deals with
the people that are elected purely for
delegates
there are a lot of issues with this
process
political parties are considered
basically semi-public organizations
they're they're half private they're
half public they're they're they're
privately run but they have an impact on
obviously public elections
so um
there there are questions raised as to
whether or not the current um delegates
would actually sustain sustain a legal
challenge because they are not in any
which way proportional
in fact it is a complete violation of
one man one vote however it is a private
organization so um
there's there's a very there's a lot of
different court cases out that surrounds
um how parties operate how they nominate
um
uh the one that i cite all the time is
actually it's a california versus uh
state democratic party which the state
democratic party of california sued um i
want to say it was a couple
it was a couple decades ago basically
telling the state of california that
they are a private organization that
they can control how they nominate their
candidates for ballot access um the
supreme court actually ruled with the
california democratic party and says yes
you are a private organization you can
control your process
so we flash to new hampshire and we have
this interesting situation where we have
the state
dictating
to political parties how to organize
giving them the option to opt out but by
having the state control it it raises i
believe constitutional questions about
one man one vote uh because the state is
actually putting forward districts that
are not in any which way proportional
represents a representative um a town of
300 gets the same
uh is guaranteed the same minimum
representation as a town of 3 400. so
that obviously creates problems
so i went to
i can't speak for my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle they're not
involved in this process but obviously
happy to hear their input
i went to um the republican party i said
hey you know we have this this problem
of
one day we might be sued and i don't
know if we would survive the challenge
once again i don't know because it's a
semi public organization i don't know
don't know which way the courts would
come down i could honest to god i could
see it going either way uh
you know we have this we have this this
issue what do you want to do in this
situation
and it it appears that the solution is
to get rid of the
the delegates all together and leave in
the clause
that says that
the nom the party nominees
will remain delegates but the state will
no longer operate the underlying
districts
and i said i would take that back to the
committee and present that to the
committee
there's a variety of reasons why i
personally believe it's it's a good idea
the first of which is i do have a
a philosophical issue with with asking
the new hampshire taxpayer to fund an
election
for a private organization
you can make the argument that we do
that via primaries but i think in that
situation the parties are operating more
in their public capacity and less in
their private capacity
in my opinion when the state is funding
an election
to elect delegates who are then electing
state committee members that that is a
largely private
function and you have a philosophical
issue with asking um taxpayers across
the political spectrum to fund an
election that is currently being
exclusively used by my party the
republican party
so that is where that is where i am at
on hb 55 if i was to vote today i would
vote to abolish the districts entirely
um i would leave the rsa in there so
that particularly the republican party
who's still using this process can still
have their process intact of having
their delegates which would be
anyone who has won a party nomination
contest
and that wouldn't severely compromise
the party but would also in my opinion
relieve the new hampshire taxpayer of
having to fund an election for what i
view as a private organization
thank you representative comments
this would be house bill
and it deals with
rsa 662
representative lane
um i appreciate this because we've had
this bill before an election law
but
this may be a dumb question why are we
considering it in this committee and why
are we discussing it i'm sorry i don't
because it's actually a districting bill
okay thank you theoretically it should
be getting based on
factors
rising out of the census it just hasn't
been
and maybe it will save us time in
election law
representative mcguire
yes thank you i would have to agree with
representative barry that this is
probably not the best way to do it
and having worked with a large number of
people there is major confusion among
the populous on what's a delegate and
why do we bother electing them
and therefore
i tend to think it might be a good idea
to let the party figure out what they
want to do for
delegates other than nominees and stay
out of it as have the legislature stay
out of it
so it it has been the determination that
this can become before this committee
from a jurisdictional issue so
um
unless there's further objection i'm
representative weber
i just have a comment and it comes out
of bewilderment
because it what i'm hearing people say
and i know nothing about the process
is that it's
very difficult and inconvenient and
confusing and i just wonder
if the easiest solution isn't for the
other party to opt out as well and do it
at their pleasure and
as the democrats do
and then we could simply repeal the
statute and have one less statute on the
books
i i just put that forward i don't want
to interfere in
a process that i'm not involved in but
listening to this discussion that's what
popped into my head so i thought i'd let
it come out of my mouth thank you
representative barry uh yes to respond
to the representative's questions um so
this process exists for any party um you
know that would that would opt to use it
so when we make these changes on a state
level
i don't think waiting for
a private entity to withdraw
um
is wise we make you know in theory we
are making a decision that would impact
all political parties in the state not
just the republican party currently it
would underneath its current structure
it would only affect them but in in
theory the democratic state committee
could meet and say that they want back
into the system and then they would be
using these
what i i believe would be deemed
unconstitutional districts um so i i
think it's i think it's uh i i don't
want to wait um
uh but i think from a you know when we
operate we operate for everyone right i
don't just operate as republican i i
represent all all people in my district
um and we have to make decisions as a
state and i think it's the best thing to
do is to
you know
the the horrific situation that i see
the apocalyptic situation is that
someone sues over these districts
and then the attorney general's office
has to then finance a defense because
this is state law and now not only do we
have the taxpayer funding an election
but now we have the taxpayers funding a
legal defense for a private entity um i
i think it's best just to take it all
off the table
most of it off most of it off the table
okay because that's your proposal as i
understood it
correct okay
thank you madam chair so i mean to be
clear the bills before this committee
because we're responsible for
redistricting
i can't let these districts stay the way
they are because they're clearly skewed
they're clearly unfair they're clearly
not representative of equal levels of
population
and i agree with representative berry i
don't know why the state would be doing
this so we would spend time on it
waiting for the party to do something
they're organizing their work i think
the best way to convey a sense of
urgency
is to
get rid of this and then you know they
have time they have months to think
about it come up with their process or
when this goes to the senate beg for an
amendment um and and then make their
case but either way it'll force them to
do the work
i'm not saying that they're
lazy and ignoring it but if i'm
prioritizing my work and
this might not matter if i was in charge
but if you repeal it well now it becomes
my priority so i'd like to see it all
stricken
all right well um
chairman representative mcdonald
i'm just curious if i could ask my
democratic colleagues how you choose
i'm sorry i didn't understand the
question
or we're discussing how to choose state
convention delegates we're just
wondering how the democrats do it where
you don't elect them on the ballot
but that that's outside of the purview
of this committee i mean i could i could
i could look it up and find out but it's
outside of the purview of the committee
at this point
yeah if you could let me know i'd
town and count our town and county
democratic organizations in order to
make sure as many that there are as many
representatives as possible
throughout the whole state but we do it
recognizing that it is not part of
the governmental structure so is it like
a caucus system
there is a list of
uh
both
on the town county and and
elected
representatives level a list of the
people who are qualified and then i
believe that there are also there are
also local
local elections so there are some people
who are there by virtue of their
position
and there are other people who are
elected by the county caucuses
okay all right
the bill clearly says each state party
convention so i'll presume that
nobody knows if or when both parties
ever use this but
um
representative barry do i understand
then that you might be requesting ols to
do an amendment to hb 55 yes madam
chairman i'm happy to lead the charge on
that and and representative smith might
do do a dueling amendment if indeed he
wants to wipe the whole thing out and
then we can have a little focus over
that
all right
okay
all right maybe we should send save that
all right so
i think we've made a couple of decisions
as a consensus by consensus on this
committee
we will be meeting
on november
3rd and 4th
to discuss
maps
that will be published for comment at
public input sessions
in rep hall the week of november 8th
i need to check on the exact dates
because i can't remember whether i have
the 8th and the 9th or the 9th or the
10th
and we will commence our executive
session
on the bills before this committee
on november 16th
to conclude by hooker by crook
by on wednesday the 17th so that these
will be reported out
by the 18th
maps to be considered by the committee
will be submitted to staff
at least 24 hours ahead of the meetings
on
november 3rd remember the
on november 3rd
and i will speak with staff about how we
organize that for purposes of
getting it together because i
i suspect we might need somebody on
staff to
to respond to your issues when you try
to submit something and it doesn't work
i'm just anticipating technology issues
madam chair the simplest thing would be
to get at least one member of staff
equipped with these programs and and
make sure they know how to print
appropriately okay because the files
the program files are fairly small and
easy to email in
it's making them
readable by people without the program
that's the challenge
all right
so that will be
to staff so that it can get to us 24
hours before the meeting and i will not
be haggling over an hour or so so if
you're getting maps at 11 instead of 10
we're gonna have to deal with it staff
is doing the best they can to help
accommodate us
as to the bills themselves i'm expecting
an amendment from representative barry
i am not expecting to be receiving maps
on hb 51 or 53
because i'm expecting that the senate
will be dealing with those primarily and
hope that they confirm that when they
have their organization meeting
so that it decreases the work for this
committee though we will be reviewing it
as it crosses over out of the senate to
us
and as to maps being submitted for
consideration by the committee we will
be dealing with hb 50 state rep hb 52
congressional districts and hb 54 county
commissioner and i will ask one more
time is the hb link
because otherwise i have multiple stops
oh
thank you i regret but thank you for
that update
all right does anybody else have any
business for this meeting
before we close it
if you don't representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair i was really
pleased to hear that uh there would be
two opportunities for the public to
weigh in on the maps
i'm hoping that as you do your
scheduling you will consider
having one of those held off-site and
not in
concord one of them in the evening so
that
folks who may be working during the day
or might be further away i think the the
county
uh hearings that we had uh or sorry
public listening sessions
uh were helpful to get lots of input
from lots of different types of people
um who may not be able to travel to
concord during the daytime
to weigh in thanks
thank you for your comment i will also
again remind the public who might be
listening
that we have
a website for you to submit testimony to
and
the goal is to have what we will be
presenting
on that website before the hearing to
provide access
and um i'll have to sort of see what
requests are going on because as far as
i know that sort of brings true for any
bill that the house
considers and i think at a certain point
we have to realize there are limits to
what we do i also have concerns quite
frankly about holding night meetings and
the safety aspect of that for people
coming in and out it was a consideration
i can tell you when we scheduled public
input sessions as to the location as to
the availability of parking and access
and i think those are exasperated at
night here in concord or
any place
but we'll i'll take a look at it
all right
i'm not seeing any other hands i want to
thank you all for joining us enjoy a
nice week off have lots of fun with the
program
and
see you with lots of paper i think
and everybody should
they want me to give you this for david
barbara
tonight
am i understanding correctly that there
are two we've now been given two thumb